[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday January
24th today's blog entry comes in two
parts part 1 in the first part of the
survey part 2 in your pants how long
have you known Hank and Katherine thanks
for asking that question puppet I've
known Hank since he was born and I've
known Katherine since I believe 1999
what do you want from us
you know puppet I think that's what the
Buddhists would call a question wrongly
phrased the question is not what do I
want from my brother the question is
what does my brother want from me and
the answer to that question is I believe
a Nintendo Wii that that's also what I
want from my brother what are you doing
I'm writing books for teenagers and
doing this weird video project with my
brother why are you doing it well I
write books because it makes me feel
less like worthless what's next well the
major next at the moment is finishing my
new and as yet untitled third book how
you doing I'm doing really well so I'll
pop it and thank you for asking what's
the best book you've read this year the
best book I read last year is probably
the Book Thief by Markus Zusak why
should it go where oh right beneath his
name I think congratulations Marcus
definitely deserved so I went around my
home library and found some books that I
think benefit from the in your pants
rule and I'd like to share them with you
you have Marcus Zusak second novel
getting the girl in your pants the
unfathomably bad the mystery of the
golden spheres in your pants rabbit at
rest in your pants man I sure am glad
you stopped popping the cheese monkeys
in your pants then we have two excellent
novels about love and promiscuity every
man in your pants and Albert Camus is
classic the stranger in your pants the
little drummer girl in your pants stop
drumming Jesus then of course you have
the Sun Also Rises in your pants which
is which is actually what the Sun Also
Rises is about the thin man in your
pants I'm just not gonna say a word the
echo maker in your pants hello hello
hello okay I never thought I would do
that in the video blog everything that
rises must converge in your pants
I should add an addendum to the in your
pants rule which is that sometimes in
your pants isn't the funniest way that
you can add to a book title for instance
will you miss me when I'm gone in your
pants is a little funny not as funny as
will you miss me when I've gone in your
pants but the funniest one I think is
will you miss me when I'm gone from your
pants believe that is an old Carter
family tune will you miss me when I'm
gone from your pants will you miss me
when I'm gone from your pants will you
miss me when I'm gone will you miss me
when I'm gone
from your pants Hank I'll see you
tomorrow